jean claude labrecque je lui ai souffert
de kodak
jean claude labrecque est un des grands
maîtres de la caméra est un des grands
bâtisseurs du cinéma québécois
ce n'était pas uniquement un grand
directeur photo c'était une grande
personne jean-claude avais je dirais le
sens de langue québécoise en trial ou nf
en 1959 il va être à tour de rôle
caméraman directeur photo et réalisateur
dès ses débuts il se démarque en signant
la direction photo du film à tout
prendre de claude jutra et de la vie
heureuse de léopold z de gilles carle et
jean-claude il représente le québec
représente le québec pour ma génération
en tout cas témoin de son époque
jean claude labrecque immortalisant 1967
la visite au québec de charles de gaulle
la nuit de la poésie de 1970 et les jeux
olympiques de montréal de 1976
curieux innovateur le documentariste
brise des conventions là on est prêt de
quelques athlètes et on a un souffle on
est porté par hu jia balles en plus
d'avoir assuré la direction photo de
films de fiction comme la femme qui boit
et la neuvaine jean claude labrecque a
réalisé plusieurs documentaires dont
hauteur d'homme un portrait choc de la
défaite électorale de bernard landry de
2003 à nous c'est sur la qualité
adepte du cinéma direct jean claude
labrecque s'est illustrée par ce qu ils
ne filmaient pas les événements mais
parce qu'il filmait les gens qui y
vivaient je pense que son peu dans
l'aide à jean claude vuemba avantage au
niveau du documentaire que de la fiction
je vous fais chevalier de l'ordre
national du québec
mais une fois honoré jean claude
labrecque laisse derrière lui une
impressionnante filmographie et l'image
d'un homme bon pour ses amis le mot qui
vient c'est un père
à la fin de sa vie jean claude labrecque
a fait lui même l'objet d'un
documentaire intitulé labrecque une
caméra pour la mémoire
lors d'une de ses dernières entrevues de
lui il voulait qu'on retienne ceci est
mise et ça va paraître dans l'écran ça
va se voir ce que je sais que 85
et c'est louis fait dépouiller mais
radio-canada moria
[Musique]